by now you will have probably heard
about Auto GPT powered by gpt4 which can
prompt itself and autonomously complete
tasks give it a mission and through a
combination of automated Chain of
Thought prompting and reflection it will
delegate tasks to itself and run until
it's done or at least until it falls
into a loop I was going to do a video
just on auto gbt but then Microsoft
launched a demo of Jarvis based on
hugging GPT I tried it out and I'm going
to show you that later but then in the
last 48 hours there were a further five
developments including the release of a
long-term memory add-on to chat gbt
called memory GPT the detail plan for a
10 times more powerful model than Gypsy
4 from anthropic and the worryingly
named chaos GPT based on auto GPT and
designed to cause maximum damage I'm
gonna try to cover it all but the first
upgrade to the original Auto GPT was to
give it the ability to write its own
code and execute Scripts as the author
of Auto GPT put it this allows it to
recursively debug and develop I'm going
to show you some amazing use cases in a
moment but this original demo caught the
attention of open ai's Andre carpathy he
called Auto GPT the next Frontier of
prompt engineering and later in the
thread said this one GPT call is a bit
like one thought stringing them together
in Loops creates agents that can
perceive think and act their goals
defined in English in prompts I think of
it as a bit like another layer of
automation where you don't have to come
up with each individual prompt just the
overall goal based on my recent video on
reflection I already thought that was
big enough news but we're actually just
getting started text-to-speech was then
added to the model and here you can see
and hear how it's going to search the
web for top digital Nomad destinations
and then consolidate the info into a CSV
file now I'm extracting information from
a relevant website about the best places
for digital Nomads including their short
descriptions and cost of living I have
successfully created the nomads of CSV
file containing the best places for
digital Nomads along with their short
descriptions and cost of living thank
you for using my assistance McKay
Wrigley showed how you can sync up
speech to text to create an app just
with your voice based on a similar
premise his coding assistant could
design a basic social network including
building and designing a front end
creating a back end with a working
database hooking them up and uploading
the code to GitHub run Jarvis yes I need
another next app with Tailwind one sec
what would you like the app to do this
time I want a basic social networking
app and it needs to have three things it
needs to have a profile creation form a
profile viewer and I also want a way to
see all the users on the network one sec
what would you like the profiles to have
a name and email and a username
I'll add those fields to the profile
schema what else can I do I want you to
optimize the site so that it works with
mobile and desktop and I also want you
to style it in like a dark mode anything
else start building I'm building the
features you asked for continuing
the app is building correctly would you
like me to deploy it I'm all done wasn't
that fast you should give me a raise
guess what we have now we have a
profiles table with the correct schema
we should be able to submit this and
this should work and if we go to our
database
is in our DV
D the game has changed everyone of
course these are not stunningly complex
projects but will this mean you can soon
create an app just by speaking your idea
into your phone in Magicka AI certainly
think so this week they debuted this
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
list and we'll review it when it comes
out but it certainly points the way
towards what the future might look like
on a more concerning note people have
already tried to use Auto GPT to cause
Mayhem giving it the goal of destroying
Humanity establishing Global dominance
causing chaos and destruction
controlling Humanity through
manipulation and attaining immortality
for good luck as I said earlier this
unrestricted agent didn't actually
achieve anything other than creating
this Twitter account and putting out a
few Sinister tweets but it is a reminder
of how important safety tests are before
an API is released that was already
enough news for one video but then
yesterday there was news of memory GPT
as the Creator put it it's Chachi PT but
with long-term memory it remembers
previous conversations here's a little
glimpse of how it will work I just made
chat CBD but with long-term memory
basically anything you say is going to
remember and it's going to make your
experience a lot more personalized let's
also tell it
that I'm launching a new project called
memory gbt which is like chat tpd but
with long-term memory it's going to say
wow cool all this stuff but now to prove
that it works I'm going to open it in a
new tab I'm going to refresh my my
window and let's also ask it if it knows
of any projects I'm working on let's ask
that and it says yeah you're working on
memory GPT which is like chat GPD
imagine the possibilities that will open
up when models like Gypsy 4 can remember
everything you've talked about in the
past just when I was getting ready to
film that video Cora released this
create a bot feature on their website
poe.com you can use either their Claude
model or chat TPT for this feature
essentially what it does is it allows
you to give a bot a certain background
and personality and then share that bot
with others to quickly demonstrate I
decided to make my bot an impatient
French film director with a pet parrot
this is all totally free you just scroll
down and click on create bot this
creates a chat bot and a URL which you
can then send to anyone you like it's
actually really fun to chat to these
personalities and of course you can do
it in the director's native tongue of
French and he will respond in kind in
fluent French one other great thing you
can try is creating two different Bots
and getting them to debate each other
here I had Nikola Tesla in conversation
with Aristotle you just create two Bots
and copy and paste the outputs it's an
amazing conversation and less than 72
hours ago the creators of Claude
anthropic announced a 5 billion dollar
plan to take on open AI TechCrunch
obtain these documents and I found two
fascinating quotes from them the model
was going to be called Claude next and
they wanted to be 10 times more capable
than today's most powerful AI which
would be gpt4 this would take a billion
dollars in spending over the next 18
months now when know some people
listening to that will say 10 times more
powerful than GT4 in 18 months that's
just not realistic just quickly for
those people here is what Nvidia say on
a recent earnings call the CEO of Nvidia
said that over the next 10 years they
want to accelerate AI by another million
x if you break that down that would be
about 10 times more compute every 20
months so the anthropic timelines look
plausible and the second fascinating
quote was this these models could begin
to automate large portions of the
economy as I talked about in my last
video we believe that the companies that
train the best 2025 26 models will be
too far ahead for anyone to catch up in
subsequent Cycles it is very tempting to
speculate as to why that might be could
it be that the frontier models that
these companies develop would then
assist those companies in developing
better models or is it that these
companies would eat up so much compute
that there wouldn't be much left for
other people to use who knows but it's
fascinating to speculate before I end
though I must touch on two last things
hugging TPT and the Jarvis model the
video was originally supposed to be
about and also safety here is the
hugging GPT demo codename Jarvis
released by Microsoft the link will be
in the description as will some
instructions on how to set it up I
should say it's a little bit hit and
miss I would call it an alpha prototype
by the way if you haven't heard of
hugging GPT check out my video on gbc4's
self-improvement essentially it uses a
gypsy model as a brain and delegates
tasks to other AI models on hugging face
when it works it's really cool but it
takes a little while and doesn't work
too often from my own experiments I've
noticed that the images have to be
fairly small otherwise you'll get an
error but let me show you one example
where it worked after setting up I asked
it this please generate an image where
four people are on a beach with their
pose being the same as the pose of the
people in this image I know there's a
slight typo but it understood what I
wanted and the image by the way is
generated from mid-journey what did the
model do well it analyzed the image used
several different models and detected
the objects inside the image it then
broke down their poses and generated a
new image with the same poses with
people on a beach that's four or five
different models cooperating to produce
an output but before I end I do briefly
want to touch on safety a lot of these
models fail quite hard they end up in
Loops but sometimes quite concerning
Loops this Auto GPT ended up trying to
optimize and improve itself recursively
of course it failed but it is
interesting that it attempted to do so
and remember this isn't the full power
of the gpt4 model this is the fine-tuned
safety optimized version and that does
make it a less intelligent version of
gbc4 as Sebastian bubeck recently
pointed out with an example over the
month so you know we had access in in
September and they kept training it and
as they kept training it I kept querying
for my unicorn in TXI okay to see
whether you know what was going to
happen and this is you know what
happened so it kept improving okay and
and and I left out the best one it's on
my computer uh you know I will maybe
review it later but uh you know it kept
improving after that but eventually it
started to degrade once I started to
train for more safety the Unicorn
started to degrade so if tonight you
know you go home and you ask gpt4 and
charge GPT to draw unicorn intixie
you're gonna get something that doesn't
look great okay that's closer to charge
GPT and this you know as silly as it
sounds this unicorn Benchmark we've used
it a lot as kind of a benchmark of
intelligence you know so yes we're not
getting the most powerful or intelligent
version of GT4 but in some circumstances
that might actually be a good thing as
you're high the creator of baby AGI
which is similar to Auto GPT
demonstrated in in this example he
tasked his model to create as many paper
clips as possible sounds good but the
model refused saying that it should be
programmed with a goal that is not
focused solely on creating paper clips
and later on said this there are
currently no known safety protocols to
prevent an AI apocalypse caused by paper
clips Ellie is a yukowski a decision
theorist and AI safety researcher
reacted like this that face when the AI
approaches AGI safety with the
straightforwardness of a child and gives
it primary attention from Step One
thereby vastly outperforming all the
elaborate dances and rationalizations at
the actual big AI labs and he ended by
saying to be clear this does not confirm
that we can use AIS to solve alignment
because taking the program with the
seriousness of a child is not enough
it's only the first step but Sam Altman
may have a different idea four days ago
he admitted that they have no idea how
to align a super intelligence but that
their best idea was to use an AGI to
align an AGI but we do not
no and probably aren't even close to
knowing how to align a super
intelligence and our lhf is very cool
for what we use it for today but
thinking that the alignment problem is
now solved would be a very grave mistake
indeed I hesitate to use this word
because I think there's one one way it's
used which is fine and one that is more
scary but uh like AI that can start to
be like an AI scientist and self-improve
um and so when like can we automate like
can we automate our own jobs as AI
developers very first the very first
thing we do can that help us like solve
the really hard alignment problems that
we don't know how to solve like that
honestly I think is how it's going to
happen so it could be that the first
task of a future Auto GPT model is solve
the alignment problem let's hope that
that prompt comes back with a positive
output thank you so much for watching to
the end and have a wonderful day